our earth manners coverage turns to a
major energy crisis affecting millions
of people's livelihoods in South Africa
widespread blackouts can cost the
country's economy up to 284 million
dollars every day but the energy
shortages are also spurring a new
generation of entrepreneurs with plenty
of sunshine each year those
entrepreneurs are creating a 19 billion
dollar solar power industry Debora patta
is just outside Cape Town with how this
could be a model for other countries in
Africa
Deborah good morning good morning I'm
here in France shocked home to wine and
food farms like this one powered by a
floating solar plant just one of the
many responses to South Africa's energy
shortage the government is battling to
keep the lights on here a decade of
mismanagement and corruption has left
the National Grid close to collapse
regularly plunging much of the nation
into darkness increasingly renewable
energy is being seen as the answer to
the problem one thing South Africa has a
lot of is sunshine $2,500 a year on
average according to the weather bureau
and that makes it ideal for the
country's solar power revolution a
revolution led by a younger generation
there was no allegiance to old ways of
doing things for our generation climate
change is obvious we not only experience
it but we're not threatened by what it
means in terms of changing the ways of
doing business in order to to respond to
that for money Tim B is a co-founder of
Pele a company committed to building
renewable energy plants across Africa
they're planted toes River near Cape
Town contributes enough energy to power
36 thousand households it's cheap it's
clean and unlike coal in endless supply
I think it's time it's history and
perhaps you know it's also an
opportunity for us to to finally get on
a development park that is sustainable
as the African continent
pila has given the residence here a 5%
stake in their company and it also
provides electricity to this local
school most of the kids here have grown
up only knowing solar energy if not only
powers a school that provides them with
hidden educational benefits they've cut
their electricity bill by half a huge
saving for a school servicing an
impoverished community and cheaper but
it's also clean right it's a really
clean electricity no pollution and it
really used the only uses the Sun can
you see Nigeria these 10 year old
students agree it is pretty mind-blowing
because it looks like just windows but
it's actually like just a generator it
makes its own power from the Sun and
it's that power that could ensure the
survival of South Africa's
internationally renowned wine country
here in Franchot the switch to solar has
been born out of necessity on the back
of more than three years of drought the
constant power outages have had a dire
effects on the farming industry this 300
year old fruit farm uses only renewable
energy Farmer France find a mirror says
it was cheaper to build this floating
solar farm a continental first and plant
more orchards we have taken so much from
this earth so I think it's time that we
give something back giving back in a way
that's good for business and good for
planet Earth for these young people
Solar is just the beginning innovation
is ongoing they tell us and will lead to
solutions we cannot even begin to
imagine right now
Nora hmm fascinating Debora patta there
are some places here in the United
States where laws have been passed
requiring solar by a certain date
generally working there